absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
what a lad well today i have one of the
more popular guests who have come on
waterload already where he told his
incredible story where he went from
picking asparagus to the warriors to the
hurricanes and then of course the all
blacks and he then somehow was allowed
to head over to france but now he's back
and i am very keen to hear what is next
for the most damaging bull runner in the
world of rugby he is one of the greats
nani lal mape welcome brother
cheers jimmy appreciate it bro
appreciate it mate good to have you back
on like i said um your first episode was
one of the greats i listened back to it
the other day awesome to hear your
journey but it means we sort of skip
forward your journey now and we can get
straight into the good stuff so
mate you're back from france how was it
over there
yeah france was um
yeah the lifestyle there was was pretty
hissing
my family my uh mavison
madison the boys loved today
i think that was one of the great things
that you know i got to experience was
that my kids got to experience nothing
that
that i ever did growing up and
um you know
they meant to go to disneyland and that
was a big dream of mine and
to my kids to do that it was pretty it
was pretty cool way so
no france was it was a good idea
had his challenges and that because
obviously it was pretty hard not to
speak the language um but in terms of
lifestyle and um
like the actual city itself and now it
was it was pretty fascinating really
yeah
how was your french did you not pick it
up like victor
no you never
no not really but not that fast but it's
pretty onto it i'm pretty slow
uh in the brain bro
so
um and now vic's a natural i saw one of
um when i was doing i was doing like the
game interview and the whole the man
started going full french
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
so yeah right but it looked like you're
living a pretty cool lifestyle over
there
yeah man it was um it was pretty cool
like um
yeah definitely felt like um
you know all the stuff that you see on
the movies yeah was definitely like um
it was definitely like um
it felt like i was yeah kind of just
living in the movie and
um
you know
every day i went to training i was going
past the archeon so
that was pretty
uh pretty cool experience
yeah that was pretty cool and what was
the rugby like yeah the robbie's pretty
uh pretty different to back home and
um i kind of didn't
didn't really play my best 40 over there
um in france
i just yeah just for me i just um
yeah it probably takes a year to get
used to playing um rugby overseas but
like i said
i've just found it really hard to
communicate with teammates
just because i couldn't speak the
language
but towards the end i started um started
playing a lot better
um but yeah there was
there was time on the field was uh
you know just yeah the language was
tough but
it was a good challenge
well that's interesting obviously i i
haven't followed it really closely but
always see the highlights and
as always coming up with some massive
place when you're needed
look like you're carving it up over
there but interesting to hear that you
had some struggles on the field yeah
yeah you know um you know
just being honest like yeah yeah um yeah
struggled at the start but i didn't
towards the end started finding my feet
again and then
yeah and then all my blew us calf and
then
she was all over
how did the um styles compare for you
like obviously coming from the canes all
blacks how did the style of rugby
compared to over there was it more kick
chase
yeah it was more um
yeah it was definitely more um
if lead
um
yeah i think for them they uh out in in
france top 40 and they like to click for
penalties
[Music]
you know everything was go for the three
points but for me i was just
trying to tell us
kick it in the corner let's have a crack
and
and the in the scrums and stuff they
would hold up all in and i'm like
you know they're trying to scrum for a
penalty but um you know for me i i want
to play with the ball and stuff but
you know that's just the way that um
you know the way the way that they play
up there
um
definitely really physical though
so pretty pretty massive dudes in the
top 14 and
um
yeah definitely physical really physical
there
ma and obviously um the pros um your
wallet's looking pretty heavy now
[Laughter]
but did you have more years on your
contract i'm sure you signed for longer
than uh what you've been over there yeah
yeah
yeah had a son three deal and um
yeah it's on through your deal and uh
yeah back after one year so
um
you know things don't work out um
sometimes but
i think for me i just had to do what's
best for um
for myself
and my family
so was that mainly because you're
struggling on the field rugby wise or
was that a family the family was
struggling with over there living what
was the sort of reason behind the the
move back
yeah
yeah for me like i just
obviously i got my oldest daughter who
still lives
here in
new zealand
she didn't go down a really tough
no i know um yeah so she wasn't allowed
to come over so oh yeah um just found it
really tough not to
to see her
you know
it was yeah it was pretty tough to be
away from her and
mostly with covenant and stuff and the
bubble and stuff she couldn't really
come over
etc etc so um being away from here was
tough
um
but yeah i also just wanted to be close
a little bit closer to my family and
stuff so
um
yeah and then
um some things happen
that i just couldn't uh
i just couldn't turn down so in the day
um i was always gonna do what's best for
me and my family
so how hard was that to get out of your
contract sometimes that can be pretty
a pretty niggly process and pretty
daunting having to go tell the big dog
it starred that you went out of the
contract how was that conversation
i know we went pretty well um
we're pretty well obviously
it was tough at the time but
um
i felt like uh
it was just you know
for me i just had to be honest with him
that i was struggling
um you know that gonna be around my
family wasn't really
enjoying um my rugby and stuff so
um obviously you know
for my family side and stuff so
yeah i just i pretty much just laid it
out um
and just told them how i was feeling um
how far i was gonna go in the future and
um
yeah and then they kind of just
understood it
um both parties um agreed that you know
the best thing was
um what's the part ways
crazy and then obviously you've spoken a
little bit about an opportunity that has
come about and i honestly have never had
so many questions around the same thing
on the instagram coming in what is nani
la mapi up to next so
what is the plans for you going forward
yeah uh yes the player for me is um
i'm gonna sign with kb steelers for the
next three years
[Music]
wow so it's just a bit
bit closer to home and
a bit closer to home so that um my
daughter could come over to japan or
um you know if i need to come back i can
shoot shoot back
was a bit closer instead of being two
days away yeah so
um
also just yeah great opportunity great
club
um you know the likes of dan carter and
cruds were there so
and plus smithy um
has a bit of involvement in there so
i feel like for me
will be easier to connect um with the
staff as
they've got a new zealand coach
there at the moment so
japan is all about attacking footy as
you know yourself so
that's the game that i want to play and
i just feel like i'll be getting tested
more um
in japan so
yeah a bit closer to home was the main
reason
and they are a club renowned for having
very deep pockets so i could imagine
they threw a fair amount of cash at you
i don't know what you're talking about
just
happy to learn japanese bro
in japanese
no that you will suit the style of um
footy over there no doubt like it is
very attacking
um that your power game will be
destructive over there there's some
they're a little bit smaller but you
know geez i feel sorry for some of those
uh 10s and 12s coming up against you
because
oh my there's a lot of players around
new zealand rugby know the power that
you can produce and about is is pretty
special
no i think for me bro i'm just
um probably in the part of my career
where i just want to be happy
i'm doing my job and
i feel like if i can get myself mentally
sharp um then hopefully i can perform to
my ability
this idea just um yeah i think good
thing for me is just knowing that i'll
be a bit closer to home
you can see my daughter um you know so
also my family can come over as well
i'm a bit closer as well so that'll be
cool
was there ever um
was it ever a thought of for you to
return back to new zealand and play back
here
uh yeah it was definitely thoughts about
it um
definitely thoughts about it but uh
i think for me that um
yeah i think for me that side's closed
hopefully one day i'll return but i
think for me it's just
um yeah that's the situation i'm in and
never know one day i might return but um
yeah but at the moment i'm really
excited to join uh kobe and
um pretty keen to rip in
value
um doing some training with the turbo
leds at the moment all right
you're not going to put the boots on
yeah
um i'm itching to pull my feet uh
to put the boots on a row um but
um it's also made like training of the
two baby boys
seeing a bunch of young fresh faces and
a bunch of old faces and especially
training with my best mate jason emery
which is pretty cool yeah um so
hopefully
i know you
know my age is probably going to be
angry but yeah i'm pretty keen to jam
for the two of jose try to do something
great here
when do you have to be to when do you
have to be back to i'll be over at japan
yeah so
my culture doesn't start to october so
oh yeah it's a bit of time
what a bit of time here so so you
mentioned uh coming back to new zealand
and having like sort of it feels like
talking to you have sort of unfinished
business here but
i am very keen to hear like what sort of
stopping you come back to new zealand
because obviously all the fans in new
zealand want you back uh everyone on the
question said that they wanted you
playing for their respective
super rugby franchise so
um sort of what's stopping you coming
back and becoming an all black again
well this yeah it's probably two parts
to it um
yeah i think for me it was uh
you know offered to come back but um
you know i was
given an option to um you know to come
back and um obviously the the hurricanes
were interested and obviously the two
beds would be interested but
um i was yeah i was told by
um yeah i was i was offered a contract
that um that the newbies
are offered and
and i just felt like in the part of my
career
um you know i know what i bring to the
table and i back myself 100
so you know they
for me it was
i had to provide um you know day i'm
provided for my kids and stuff so there
was no way that was going to take a back
step um
but my ego and my
my competitiveness you know still has
unfinished business and
like i want to come back and and give it
a crack and prove it to myself not to
anyone else but just prove it to myself
that
that i can still do it but um
in a day i have to look after my family
and um
you know for me but coming from growing
up with not much um
i know my biggest fear is finishing the
game
with nothing to to show for you know and
i feel like
after
after my rugby career and if i had to go
back to work that you know to
you know i don't know if i had to go do
a
nine-to-five job that i hate you know i
feel like my robbery career will be
a waste you know because in a day you
can get all these trophies but
for me um putting my kids
in a bit of situation that i could um
put them in a better situation that that
i was growing up and i feel like that's
a bigger
bigger reward to me than any um trophy
or any accolades so
um and also the second one was you know
i feel like
um
yeah for me i feel like i've closed that
chapter on on new zealand rugby and i
feel like for me now i was focusing on
playing good rugby for kobe and
if i'm good enough to play for tonga
i'll put my hand up
for tongan
and represent the read on what um if i'm
good enough and if i get picked
what is the process there at the moment
where you at i know you've called out um
world rugby a few times trying to get
them to give you uh an exemption but
where are you at are you a chance to get
to the rugby world cup with tonga
no so i think i'm a month late at the
moment which is kind of annoying yeah
so
yeah i just feel like yeah i don't know
why you should have to stand down three
years
uh
if you're gonna go play for your you
know your country of your parents birth
you know you see what the rugby league
boys are doing
um you know the movement that the tongan
boys did i mean that pretty much made
everyone watch rugby league
international again and
you know you saw the support that tonga
got
from all their big names going back and
um yeah to me it just sounds crazy that
you have to stand down three years
wanting to play for your
you know
um play for your your parents nation it
just
doesn't sound right to me when um
you know
doesn't sound right but you know there's
the rules and
um you know but imagine if
you know that
imagine if there was other players that
could jump on board earlier so that
you know that the
that the smaller nations could get them
in their prime instead of um
waiting three years and you know they're
a bit older
a bit you know so
this is my little one percent anyway it
would be awesome to see you at the rugby
world cup with tonga they've obviously
already got some pretty talented backs
out there already um playing in the
pacific nations cup recently uh
jeez you would add a nice string to that
uh backline yeah because um
i heard you're half tongue i think they
you need a first five or something
i'm sure your name is
so you got a little bit of tongue blood
in you mate oh mate they've got willie
harville who runs a very good cat and um
i think he would yeah he does you're
outside him um could be dangerous with
the likes of pear tower and philao and
fekita
that is that is a pretty special
backline
i think i'll just be in the 923 yeah
just go for now
nah well i'll be i'll be yeah like i
said man like if i'm good enough then
i'll definitely put my hand up but
um at the moment focus on kobe
um and just being a fan and then once
this little
once this little uh
little lockdown is done then i'll put my
hand up
and what about um league obviously you
could play for
um tonga and league was there ever a
option for you to go back to the league
go back to the warriors or another club
yeah definitely like um
for me like you know i played league win
you know
i played league early in my career and i
probably wasn't um i was probably just
mucking around and
just didn't really
do wasn't really professional i wasn't
really professional and
i didn't really take care of my body and
stuff like that um
you know i still
you know
i feel like i have a little bit of
unfinished business in rugby league but
i feel like about way back now it's
probably
probably too late
for me to go back now and give it a
crack so
um
yeah still
like yeah but then i think about the
league preseason and i'm like nah i'm
all good
come on bro you see me run
you see me do foot in the stocks
is the league pre-season way harder than
any super rugby preseason you ever did
oh yeah
yeah
100
just yeah it's like
it's like eight to ten weeks before
christmas and then you got another
another i think eight weeks
after christmas uh yeah but you know
obviously and
and robbie you only get you know is it
two weeks before christmas
yeah sounded like that two to three
weeks and then
um
and then you know you got
probably what three weeks after new
year's and then two pre-match uh
pre-season games and then you're into it
you know so
it's definitely a lot of running a
league i've yeah i believe
league is a tough game bro tough tough
game right that's interesting because i
always thought you were struggling in
the hurricanes pre-seasons you must have
just got that
face going where you pretend you're
working hard but uh you're actually
sweet
yeah
but
yeah i thought i'd
yeah i was always in the extras group
cheers davey stash
oh but look at you now oh
on plenty with kobe mate like i said at
the start as always
i do put the questions out to the
instagram and i did get heaps so i am
keen to try and get through as many as i
can and a lot of them were obviously
around the all blacks
um
and would you return back to new zealand
everyone wants you back at their
franchise but we did get a few other
good ones as well money and goals aside
which code did you enjoy the most and
why
no for me i definitely enjoyed the
hurricanes um the most that's the team
that
that i um
yeah that's a team that i just loved
running up at westpac stadium um
for me yeah i still think about those
times
that i'd run on you know in steam and
wellington
um for me it doesn't get much better
than that cleveland hurricanes
alongside next to you you did some
special things on that field in front of
those fans
i see why it sits so highly
in your memories
it'll be good to see again too jeez it
would be good to have you back i
think i'm getting
i think i'm on that declining side now
bro getting old you'd look quite good in
red and black by the way
congrats on that coaching job
like kobe crusaders you're slowly
getting into the reader i like where
you're going
okay next one how has europe changed
your game
um
yeah i think for me it's just probably
more my um my kicking game
um
you know
obviously in
um in europe
you know they like to put little little
grubbers through and and pressure that
the teams
um that you know that way
because uh
in europe they defend a little bit
different they only have one at the back
and they have 14 in the line which is
different to new zealand when they have
um when they have two full backs and you
know and line speed but
in europe they're kind of 14 in line and
one at the back and it's it's pretty
hard to break the line
um in europe so definitely looking for
more kick space
especially with the
um
of the 50 to
50 22 now so
yeah all right you might be if you go
back to leg you'll be in the halves
no i think i'll be 18 men
okay next question
how to overcome being underestimated
this is a good one
i think for me yeah i think for me when
um
when that blues article i mean so when
um
when the article came out on the week
when we played the blues
um
you know
they came out and then well i just read
it like
every time i ran out to training and
then i did it before the game and i was
i was in the mood
that game and
i think for me it's just funny something
that
that ticks you off and that article
definitely ticked me off and
um
yeah and then
yeah
obviously i'm not saying read an article
but i'm just
saying like you know find something that
ticks you off and you know definitely
get you
over that line well well that's what
happened to me so right you knew you
jeez you hit beast mode that game that
was one of the greats
but how was the media over in france was
did you feel media pressure over there
or were they nice to hear or
sure it's not even no way because yeah i
can't read french so
they could have been saying whatever and
i was like
you know we we you know just saying yeah
thanks you know messi yeah
i think they were running um stuff for
me when i first got there and
then you know towards the end they were
starting to
um ease into a little bit and but it was
yeah it was you know um it is what it is
you know if you're not performing
um you know but yeah it definitely eased
up towards the end when i was playing
better so okay next one best player
league or union that you played with um
the best player that i have played with
um
definitely beating a booty um
yeah when i was with him in the
hurricane he was just
he was yeah he was on fire bro and
i just love running
like you know i mean he would attack the
line i just love being there
with them because you know at the end of
the day they
they had to mark one of like you know
they had to double team one of us
otherwise one of us would be gone and
um
so i just felt like
and plus body did things that
anybody could do you know it was that
quick
and he was just so calm about everything
he did
now he's definitely the best player that
um
that i you know and
he will just pull the trigger on a lot
of things that
other players would um
second guess he'd just if he saw me on
the wing he'll just cross-field it to me
straight away or
um so yeah no definitely bad
he's a freak
love that answer couldn't agree more
okay next one this is from another
hurricane teammate of yours via for feta
he wants to know how much your new
contract is worth
no
no not nothing very just like a super
just grateful to learn japanese bro
just i'm gonna be eating some ramen
[Laughter]
right the media's gonna get hold of how
much your contract's worth some some i
don't know how they do it but sometimes
they get figures eh um
and you aren't oh i think it's gonna
blow some people's minds
no i think no like i said bro i just
want to take some ramen and
leave some japanese
okay next question
[Laughter]
absolutely okay next question is from
our major sponsor swish so if you could
get a video shout out from any celebrity
who would it be and why
uh well yeah i think for me it'd
definitely be lebron james yeah yeah
right just
a big fan
just a big fan he just loves what he
does for um
for the you know obviously he met at
school um
he definitely made a school um well
you know back at his
his state in that um so that's one of my
goals as well so i think for me
obviously not at school but
it was kind of sad
yeah this contract
no this is not a school but like
yeah give back definitely not a school
but just like a program that helps
um
unprivileged kids with rugby boots and
stuff like that so
obviously with
um the japan season not been as long
um i'll definitely have more time back
in parmi so
uh for me i could definitely help out
with next generation
mate you are an absolute lad love that
okay next one apparently you're a dark
horse goal kicker
really
someone cheat me up or
none
if it went to a penalty shootout needed
five kickers would you would you put
your hand up as one of them it depends
on what two more
and the fragile cat final
yeah
yeah hard up right yeah you're in there
right yeah definitely
definitely uh definitely i'd want that
pressure because um
if i miss
you know
people came at me i wouldn't really care
i'll just keep going off my life you
know so
yeah
take one for the team
the confidence of the man though you
back yourself in any any situation like
that that way
yeah well i think for me it's just
you have to back yourself otherwise
what you're doing you know for me is
like
you know i
you know you have to back yourself you
know because
what's going to get you up in the
mornings when you're not
um wanting to train you know
so
obviously
me backing myself um
that means no disrespect to anyone else
but
if you put in the work then you know why
not go out there and back yourself and
express yourself
um obviously i don't back myself in the
um gold kicking piano the shooter but
um
i'll give it a crack because you know
anything for the team all right how good
that's why you're one of the greats okay
next one
where are the all blacks in new zealand
rugby union going wrong at the moment
a lot of people want to know this what's
what's wrong up top
oh i don't
for me i i'm not too sure but i'm just
trying to figure out um you know
um just trying to figure out my
situation i can't really speak
too much on the nzlu um
that's a load and they just fixed
you yeah
yeah definitely someone's trying to
throw me on the bus
no
but yeah no like i actually don't know
um yeah
i think for me i'd love to see old um
old rugby players um involved more
and
um
you know an nsu so but
um yeah i don't i don't have the answer
but
i know i know that they will bounce back
and i know um they're heading in good
direction cool okay last question one
piece of advice for what a lead listener
i know you've you've picked up a lot
since you're moving over to france so
i'm always keen to hear a bit of advice
from you
yeah i think for me it's just uh um
i think for me it's just family first
always um
you know in the day
um
you know you'll have people come in and
out of your life but you know their
families there
um to the end so
for me it's just about
taking care of my family and
you know
like i said
um
you know
you know i'd give up my dream just to so
that my family could live a
better life so
um yeah family first always
that's powerful like that and that's
obviously coming from someone who spent
some time in france away from one of
their uh children so
um um awesome awesome advice awesome
catching up with you thanks for coming
on the podcast again and like i said the
first one was a great i think we just
topped it
some real some real good juice in that
one um you're an absolute lad love love
what you do love what you're about um
you always you're always open and honest
with where you're at and and rugby and
what you want to achieve so
and you i know you spoke about bodhi
highly but i'm sure it'd speak highly
about you um playing inside you as is
something pretty special which um some
guys are lucky enough to experience but
it's been awesome having you on the
podcast mate and um yeah looking forward
to following the rest of your journey
cheers t cheers bro appreciate it
you're a led
[Music]
what
[Music]